mit der libyenkonferenz in berlin im
jänner 2020 kam wieder etwas hoffnung
auf dass die kampfhandlungen eingedämmt
werden könnten
vor allem sollten die kriegsparteien
neuerlich auf politische lösungen
eingeschworen werden
doch wie realistisch ist das in einem
konflikt der zunehmend von ausländischen
interessen dominiert wird heute in
prächtiger kompakt libyen ihr garten zum
frieden
[Musik]
nachdem die offensive von general
haffter im sommer 2009 10 vor den toren
der hauptstadt tripolis zu fliegen kann
stellte sich die frage wie es
weitergehen kann
es gab ja schon oft versuche von
internationaler seite einen
waffenstillstand zu vermitteln und
verhandlungslösungen zu finden
doch immer wieder wurden vereinbarungen
gebrochen und die kämpfe sind neu
aufgeflammt erschwerend kommt hinzu dass
die kontrahenten von verschiedenen
seiten unterstützt werden die ihre
eigenen interessen verfolgen
auf seiten von haffter befinden sich zb
russland saudi arabien ägypten und die
vereinigten arabischen emirate während
der übergangspräsident auf die hilfe der
türkei und der usa zählen kann
hinderlich ist auch die uneinigkeit der
eu mitglieder frankreich und italien
so unterhält paris beziehungen zu haften
während roms arash unterstützt eine neue
dynamik brachte im dezember 2009 10 die
ankündigung der türkei eigenes militär
zur unterstützung von sarahs nach libyen
zu entsenden
eine kritische entwicklung der russische
private militärfirmen bereits in
diensten general haft stehen daraufhin
drängte deutschlands kanzlerin angela
merkel auf eine internationale libyen
konferenz gemeinsam mit dem
un-generalsekretär wurde am 19 jänner
der berliner prozess gestartet
allerdings waren nicht alle wesentlichen
akteure eingeladen oder lehnten ihre
teilnahme ab daher takten zwar russlands
staatspräsident putin us-außenminister
pompeo der britische premier
die startchancen und der türkische
präsident erdogan aber die beiden
rivalen savas und haffter fehlten
was ist dabei herausgekommen erstens die
bekräftigung des bereits im vorfeld
verhandelten waffenstillstand dafür wird
eine militärkommission gebildet in der
jeweils fünf militärische vertreter der
konfliktparteien unter leitung des un
sondervermittler einen dauerhaften
waffenstillstand aushandeln sollen
zweitens um den prozess zu unterstützen
einigte man sich auch auf ein
umfassendes waffenembargo
bis zur wiederaufnahme eines politischen
fahrplan sollen sämtliche
kampfhandlungen ruhe
drittens die rückkehr zu einem
politischen prozess unter libyscher
verantwortung dafür sollen die
konfliktparteien einen fahrplan
ausarbeiten
es gilt in monatlichen folgetreffen auf
unterschiedlichen politischen ebenen
konkrete zwischenergebnisse zu erörtern
und in einem internationalen ausschuss
für folgemaßnahmen weitere schritte zu
setzen
und viertens in der abschlusserklärung
wird noch einmal darauf hingewiesen dass
nur die staatliche libysche
ölgesellschaft noz das recht hat öl und
gas zu handeln damit sollen illegale
verkäufe unterbunden werden
wie ist das nur einzuschätzen im grunde
genommen versuchten die teilnehmer das
nachzuholen was seit dem sturz gaddafis
2011 nicht funktioniert hat nämlich die
konfliktparteien an den
verhandlungstisch zu bringen und
kampfhandlungen zu stoppen
nachdem sich bislang keine
konfliktpartei militärisch durchsetzen
konnte sollte das vielleicht diesmal
möglich sein
es ist ermutigend dass zwölf staaten
darunter die wesentlichen unterstützer
der kriegsparteien aus dem ausland die
abschluss erklärung unterzeichneten
damit sollten sie ihre waffen
lieferungen einstellen und dem
politischen prozess fördern
es wäre ja eigentlich auch in ihrem
interesse dass libyen nicht weiter in
anarchie versinkt und zum vollkommen
unberechenbaren nachbarn oder zum
idealen rückzugsraum für extremisten und
terroristen wird irritierend ist dabei
dass italien und frankreich weiterhin
unterschiedliche ziele verfolgen
sie ziehen nicht an einem strang obwohl
sich beide unlängst bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz
zu den zielsetzungen des berliner
prozesses bekannten das erschwert auch
die positionierung der eu und ihre
handlungsfähigkeit die
auseinandersetzungen um die
neugestaltung der marine operation sofia
veranschaulichen die problematik und
unendlichkeit
dabei geht es vorrangig um die
durchsetzung des waffenembargos und die
bekämpfung des schlepper wesens jüngste
meldungen über waffenlieferungen aus der
türkei lassen auch zweifel an der
einhaltung der zusagen anderer staaten
aufkommen
entscheidend wird aber sein wie
ernsthaft die rivalen vor ort an einer
verhandlungslösung interessiert sind und
ob sich deren unterstützer an ihre
verpflichtungen halten solange
ungehindert waffen ins land fließen und
libyen als geopolitisches schachbrett
gesehen wird kann es keine substanzielle
verbesserung geben
ein ausblick liebe entsteht wieder auf
der internationalen agenda
das ist der positive ausblick nach den
gesprächen in moskau berlin und münchen
denn ohne mitwirkung und unterstützung
von außen kann dieses land keinen
frieden finden
schon in den nächsten wochen wird sich
zeigen ob es wieder einmal bei
absichtserklärungen bleibt oder
tatsächlich fortschritte erzielt werden
können
die einhaltung des waffenembargos sowie
die monatlich geplanten treffen werden
dabei aufschlussreich sein
[Musik]